when after when state after state Donald
Trump has figured out how to lead the
Republican presidential race by
promoting ideas that hope to scale back
civil liberties imposed protectionists
laws and act a bomb friendly foreign
policy create barriers with other
nations and wait a second this stuff
sounds kind of familiar huh that's
because everything this wailing orange
suitcase of crazy talks about is just a
repackaged form of attitudes and
policies pushed by mainstream
conservatives and Republicans for
decades in fact here are six ways
conservatives and the GOP originated all
Donald Trump's ideas you might even say
they created him number six that God
dang wall Trump keeps talking about I'm
the one that wants the wall I'm the one
that can build the way I'm not gonna pay
for that [ __ ] wall it's not even an
original idea Republicans have been
ginning up their base with demands for
some kind of barrier with Mexico for
years and complete the dang fins I'll
also complete the fence build the dang
fence and of course there have been the
various bills in Congress through the
years that promise to secure the fence
or finished the fence pleased that you
all are here to witness the signature of
the secure fence act of 2006 of
reinforced double layer fencing along
the southern border of the United States
700 miles of fencing on the border the
only difference between Trump and
Republicans on this is that Trump sells
the shitty idea with as much gusto as a
late-night infomercial billy mays here
with shore bees he will build the wall
it has the strength and the muscle a big
beautiful powerful vacuum actions
powerful wall which brings us to number
five a big middle finger to immigrants
who knows where Donald Trump learned
this load of [ __ ] about immigrants from
Mexico when Mexico sends its people
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime they're rapists to pay attention
because this rhetoric isn't that far off
from writers and contributors past and
present a conservative magazine a parrot
eyes National Review just that
immigration is out of control the
country is being transformed against its
will high levels of immigration are
incompatible with the goals and
characteristics of modern society
immigrants to this country have to learn
English at the same time I think the
impact on the voters has been to push
them in the direction of saying look the
social fabric of America is being
destroyed so why won't Nashville review
put a ring on Trump
important lessons he has for the
Republican Party but is a deeply flawed
vessel sorry Donald National Review just
isn't interested in dating you publicly
yet for now they're just gonna fill you
up in the back seat of a car deny it
later number four is taking a [ __ ] on
Muslims I think Islam HS Donald J Trump
is calling for a total and complete
shutdown of Muslims entering the United
States Oh Don you're dangerous ideas are
only eclipsed by your chances of getting
melanoma from a tanning bed that being
said at least Republican Congressman
Peter King of New York called out
Trump's ban is not so on its face
daddums have always taken at the extreme
and detectives extreme which really goes
beyond the beyond American values except
the king is probably the worst person in
Washington to criticize anyone for going
beyond American values of Muslims
unfortunately we have a too many mosques
in this country ouch and boy does he
want to make their lives a living hell
through surveillance at profiling I
believe that should be much more
surveillance in the Muslim community
here in the United States hey just like
another guy we know I want surveillance
of these people and I don't care number
three is that whole defense spending
peace through strength [ __ ] we need
to build our military so big so strong
so powerful that nobody nobody is going
to mess with us you're that clapping
it's because conservative elites have
had war boners ever since the Cold War
started they've been really successful
in graining it into their base that the
only way to achieve peace is through
buying a lot of bombs and bullets and
kick ass and stuff although they prefer
the phrase American strength what we
want to be so strong and have a military
so capable and a president so committed
to American strength that no one would
ever test our resolve American strength
is necessary to deal with these threats
it's not American strength that's
provocative as Obama believes its
American weeked okay you know we're
gonna make it so strong nobody's going
to want to mess that's really what we
have to do it number two is Chinese
trade protectionism let me tell you
about China we're going to take on new
trade deals with China Chinese currency
cheating they beat us by manipulating
their currency I'm totally
kara if they don't treat us fairly
labeling a country a currency
manipulator and sparking a possible
trade war may be a dumb idea for
presidential candidate former Republican
presidential candidate Mitt Romney seem
to think so when he derided Trump in a
recent speech he has proposed 35-percent
tariff like penalties would instigate a
trade war and that would raise prices
for consumers kill our export jobs and
lead entrepreneurs and businesses of all
stripes to flee America you're probably
seeing where this is going by now Romney
advocated for something very very close
to Trump's plan for China back when he
was running for president 2012 big
endorsement for mr. Trump today very
pleased he's a man who's created a lot
of jobs and he shares my concern about
China wow this [ __ ] is straight out of
the twilight zone I will label China a
currency manipulator they are the single
greatest currency manipulator that's
ever been on this planet once that label
has been affixed the president is able
to apply tariffs you can't deal in China
with that Dara where the President
believes that there are unfair trade
practices have cost American jobs or
killed American industries oh come the
[ __ ] on okay here's the number one way
GOP errs and conservatives created
Donald Trump I'm here because I'm a
guest of President Bush they've been
inviting him to speak at their events
for years no seriously Trump has been
invited to conservative events for years
to rally crowds and walk around the
apprentice theme and improvise speeches
on the fly in short as conservatives we
have to appreciate someone like Donald
Trump and his values from the
Conservative Political Action Conference
to GOP convention events to endorsements
of failed presidential candidates to of
all things the family leadership summit
yeah Donald Trump the guy who once joked
about dating his daughter gave a speech
at a family leadership event and got
applause Wow thank you very much that's
really nice thank you if anything
explains Trump's popularity its
conservatives playing God and inviting
him to be a part of their movement then
when they were too obsessed with
people's sex lives and starting wars in
the Middle East and stuff he became
their monster candidate let's just hope
he doesn't kill anyone this election
season it could stand in the middle of
Fifth Avenue and shoot somebody and I
wouldn't lose any voters
you